let's jump to the story from the post
millennial fetterman to stay in hospital
for weeks for depression treatment
senior Aid okay so he gets admitted to
the hospital because he's lightheaded
the dude had a very serious stroke and
now he's suffering from the thing where
he can't understand words anymore he
then gets lightheaded has to go to the
hospital again now he's depressed now he
can't work so what are they gonna do so
how long until you think Biden or no
it's going to be who's the governor
Shapiro that's right how long until he
appoints Veteran's wife Pennsylvania yes
how long until he appoints Veteran's
wife to the Senate well the good news is
as far and I hate to say this because
Shapiro wants to run for president and
be the first Jewish president
um and of all the people I've heard of
being the first Jewish president at the
moment Shapiro looks like the most
likely he's not he does not appear to be
crazy
um now he was running against
um Trump's candidate that mastriano who
was completely crazy
um you think he was crazy yes why did
he's ready because he's attending how
about just he attends Q Anon rallies do
not tell me you guys are into Q Anon no
we have masterion on the show Once yeah
legalized weed he said no so I was kind
of like a
Libertarians are in the chat are going
to lose it
um oh we can do that but we but we do
have to get to my comments on Nikki
Haley
um and so Federman is in the senate in
the first place never forget because of
Donald's Trump uh endorsing mastriano
and and
um who do you think Trump should have
not endorsed anyone in the Pennsylvania
race or was masciano particularly uh
divisive to it was I mean the whole
thing basically from January 11th all of
these candidates running on 2020 being
stolen how was it that I knew a year
before the election huh he ran on One
Promise didn't keep it not gonna win
what a shocker that he didn't win of
course and he was running against you
know a guy with c seen all dementia who
was a even when he was firing on
all cylinders so yeah with with with
with the crime I mean things looked
pretty good but only Trump could have
lost that election after all of the
antifa and the Looting
while Republicans didn't understand
ballot harvesting they did not
understand the procedure it's all true
he's lost the last three election cycles
for us yeah when he uh and the last one
the midterms oh my gosh things couldn't
have been set up more beautifully for us
but I think it's about harvesting
because well that's a very bad thing we
need to do it too
yes
um I think uh Lauren bobert's district
is a good example where she narrowly
wins by only a few hundred votes and
you're asking yourself whoa whoa whoa
whoa how does that happen this is a this
is like a rural conservative District
ballot harvesting she's kind of naughty
I think she's all right we had her on
the show I think the issue is that it
doesn't you you don't need to convince
someone to vote for you anymore they
show up knock on the door and say
Republicans are fascists right fill out
the ballot and then people go well you
got it they figured out that Democrats
are low information voters and always
have been conservatives and the factions
within the right and Republican argue
with each other oh yes right so you
might think she's nutty she might think
you're naughty and you're both trying to
exist in a similar space whereas
Democrats don't know anything right and
are just told to vote and do that's why
that's why they want 16 year old
absolutely right
so the only answer is ballot Harvest
back I guess well the answer is you
should have to show up and vote in
person fight your way past the Black
Panthers go into the ballot room
doing secret ballot I I would get rid of
all mail-in ballots and that was hurt
Republicans most of all I mean probably
we should allow states to have with an
excuse a mail-in ballot if that's not
supposed to say but the Democrats I
would even be willing to sacrifice those
and who and look make Election Day a
national holiday how about that national
holiday but you have to show up in
person because Democrats have always
cheated there are a million different
ways they cheat ballot harvesting is one
of many but understanding these were Lee
I'm doing air quotes for illegal because
the question the question is
constitutionality yes in in Pennsylvania
a lower Court ruled it was
unconstitutional to create Universal
mail-in voting but it was done with the
legislator with Republicans and
Democrats and then what happens is
Democrats imagine New York City One
activist how many doors can they knock
on in one hour when you go into one
building exactly and Republicans have to
drive I mean if you're gonna if you're
gonna no but it's more than that that's
why the what you were just saying about
how many can you knock on how many doors
can you knock on a day that's why when
they extend mail-in ballots for like six
months before the election that gives
them a lot of time they can drag their a
lot of time to knock on doors you are
absolutely right about that the more
time they have and look if they wanted I
don't care they're driving people who
are you know fetterman's mentality to
the poll and tell them how to fill it
out but you got one day to do all your
cheating here's here's the the issue I
see as I've been describing in the past
couple of weeks the United States is
suffering from left left hemisphere
hypoxia
you know they say when you're on an
airplane put on your oxygen mask before
you put on the mask of the person
sitting next to you because if you
become hypoxic you become delirious and
you can't function there are these
videos where they'll put people in a in
a pressurized chamber and they'll start
lowering the oxygen percentage while
having them answer math questions oh
really the people who are becoming
hypoxic don't know there's chicken
scratching and writing gibberish garbage
their brain tells them they're correct
and then when they increase the oxygen
back to normal they go whoa wait a
minute what did I write I didn't even
realize your brain's not working so
here's what happens
the Democrats are going after what I
would describe as the hypoxic voter
seven years
of resubject yeah and they're swimming
in it
so they say your body is completely
reborn every seven years right every
cell in your body has changed for seven
years these are people whose entire
existence is within the confines of the
media narrative fake news machine lying
about everything that is the left turn
hemisphere of our country's brain
shriveled withered and hypoxic how do
you get the and they're voting yes so
the problem is you will get a calm
rational like even Bill Maher who's a
liberal will complain about wokeness and
say there's something wrong with this
he's trying to to understand but even he
is somewhat trapped in that in those
fake narratives he's going to be in my
sane liberals club right oh nice but so
how do you convince someone like imagine
this imagine on a plane and all of the
oxygen masks drop down everyone on the
right side of the plane puts their mask
on all of the mass on the left are
broken and then when the people on the
right are saying put them put this mask
on they're going get away from me you
fetched and they're swinging at you then
they say we're gonna we want the pilot
to press the emergency button you're
like no stop you're hypoxic you don't
know what you're doing
and that's what that's how I view what's
going on I love that that's my analogy
so the so the issue is
you get people like saying liberals like
Bill Maher people like me people like
Dave Rubin former liberals classic
liberals people who have not found
themselves to becoming conservative you
will go to traditional liberals and
desperately beg them to please just read
the article from The New York Times that
says this and they go uh no
they're absolutely right completely
demoralized and then they will vote
unlike that it's a very womanly party
yeah yeah why do you think you and some
other sort of people who started left
were able to put on oxygen masks though
yeah like what how come some of you are
making it out there is the same liberal
liberals Club but a majority of people
can't well I think it has to do with
even if your oxygen mask is on the
signals from your brain can't travel to
the rest of your body if you have no
spine so for many of these people it
just didn't work there was no hope well
what I mean by that is there are a lot
of people who know they're lying there
are a lot of people who are liberal who
are just like hey man if I speak up look
I get messages all the time from people
who are like I really love your show I
respect what you do and then I say hey
man you should speak up
I I know pro athletes and they'll say
they'll message me saying like I wish I
could but I'll lose everything and I'm
like no it's true but I'm like dude you
don't need to come out and wave a trump
flag all right you simply need to come
out don't when someone says something
won't go I don't know about all that
that's it that's all I'm saying you're
totally right they won't do it they
won't well they might you gotta shake
some of them are so I think a lot of why
you never went crazy and like to answer
your question why some people don't get
hypoxic mentally is um like high
altitude training if you're constantly
working the muscle you're kind of able
to resist that's a that's a good point
yeah so for for me I was traveling
around I was doing news I was going to
Trump rallies so when a story would come
aren't they fun they were fun and
Trump's a comedian he's hilarious so not
so funny anymore not any he's lost it
he's doesn't have that same comedic uh
some people still really like what he's
saying but I do think he's lost a bit of
it
um or a lot of it I should say but I
would go to a trump rally and then I
would talk with a trump supporter and I
remember I'm in Fort Lauderdale this is
2016 right 2016. yeah that was great I'm
in Fort Lauderdale and I'm talking to a
woman I was thinking I was living in
Miami and she I think yeah so maybe it
might have been 2015. and she says I've
never voted before I'm not a republican
I'm an independent but Trump seems he's
the only person talking about issues
that that affect me and my family
so then I would go to The Newsroom at
fusion and they would say Trump is
courting white supremacists and I would
go no the lady I met was like a
construction worker or something and
they're like that's not true they're all
Nazis they're all racist and I was like
no I'm pretty sure that lady in Florida
was just like some right one of the one
of the ladies I talked to was Hispanic
no no no no no oh Hispanics loved him in
2016. especially in Florida I said yes I
spend Christmas in in Palm Beach and I I
was going around to Christmas parties
2000 oh this is 2015 and so when he
first announced and
and Wilbur Ross who has a place in Palm
Beach he was like wandering around like
a zombie Starstruck and he kept going up
to everyone at these Christmas parties
saying I don't understand it we're all
for Jeb and the Hispanic help is all for
Trump
trump I I I met a lot of Hispanic people
uh in Florida who were just like we know
what socialism is man Bernie scares us
and oh my God that's not surprising to
me you know 2016 I thought
um my full
um it was like a full-time job going
around to bars in New York and
convincing Bernie supporters that they
had to vote for Trump full-time job or
full-time hobby because I feel like I
would have so much fun doing that well
you can love yourself but but between I
mean among the three of them actually
among all the candidates Bernie and
Trump were the closest at least in what
Trump said yeah Trump was great on the
campaign Trail I mean I still didn't
expect him to win I thought for sure the
cop military complex had him down
Hillary had it and then when he when he
won I was like like knocked out of
breath but then he went on script right
after he got elected he started reading
off a prompt and that he hadn't done it
the entire time he was running and I was
like this guy's just a sham isn't he
he's just a fake and then he made John
Bolton one of his dudes the war machine
moved on he did get us out of
trans-pacific partnership I think he I
don't know if he realized the level that
the liberal economic order was planning
to become the New World Order no no no
it's not like don't give me the oh we
try this you know too bad he wasn't
president he didn't try he didn't care
he wanted to sit in bed and tweet that
trans-pacific partnership I never told
anyone this because I'm very
um I'm I'm a vault if if I talk to a
politician but it it leaks like two
months later so I can say it now I went
to see Trump like February
um of 2017 after he was elected and I
just stood at the Resolute desk and
yelled at him for 15 minutes and I
didn't use the f word first but once he
used it oh was that flying so I think
the entire West Wing heard it and that's
how it eventually leaked but
trans-pacific partnership I said what
are you doing what are you doing where
is it you haven't done any you're not
starting on the wall you haven't done
anything with trans-pacific partnership
and he he didn't know we didn't care Kim
Kardashian was his next appointment did
you feel like that was the problem with
Trump's uh time in office that he didn't
have enough people pushing him
look he ran for president before at this
point Tim Poole was in sixth grade when
Trump first ran for president 2000
I don't know when was he running on no
because it was uh it was Obama Reform
Party right yeah and what did he run on
he ran on
um Obama not being born in this country
than I am mind you no is that weird for
a long time activates the crazies it
doesn't work
the
the fiction since 2016 haven't worked
activating the crazies this way that way
that the election was stolen
um the one time he won was when he ran
on my book adios America
it was just something he thought that
might work
and so he ripped off the arguments in a
rather stupid and ignorant way still he
was making the arguments I would write
in Trump We Trust again because given
the options but he believes none of it
he understands none of it of course he
could have fired right which is who gave
him your book right like I feel like he
must have ever thought this might want
people but who was like you should read
this book it's a good idea right because
it would I think it was wrong he knew
when he ran and I was making fun of him
on the on the when he ran the first time
on the Obama birth certificate one of my
friends was a reporter in New York and
he said he's reporting on Trump and
they're all and he was threatening to
run for president he's talking about the
Obama birth certificate and my friend
um I think it was New York Times
Reporter anyway he emailed me and said
everybody else who says you're wrong
about the birth certificate he's
denouncing he's calling these horrible
names and somebody yelled out hey Ann
Coulter says
um whatever I had said about him being
completely wrong it was a crazy idea and
my friend said he started to attack
because that was the mode he was in
oh I know what it was it was
specifically Ann Coulter says you're
never going to run and he starts to do
the attack and then pulled back and said
well she'll just have to wait and see so
he knew to be careful about Crossing me
even back then and he had invited me to
lunch which I went to only because I
wanted when I walk on the beach in Palm
Beach to jump over and go in the
swimming pool
um and so he had been appealing to me I
think he had just like this animal sense
of she says things that are popular with
Americans yeah interesting but I think
that was the end of it he obviously did
not care about immigration but he so he
didn't come through with his immigration
platforms but was polling pretty well up
until kovid do you think that the
American public also forgot that he had
promised to do all these things I mean
no I think the only votes Trump got were
were opposition votes really took Biden
and the craziness and antifa and and
black lives matter matter and even
though he all he did was tweet Law and
Order exclamation point at least he's
not these people yeah but the black
lives matter summer was like pretty
crazy that wasn't enough to push him
over the edge he didn't well a he didn't
do anything yeah he couldn't he should
have brought in the military yeah he
should have Portland especially after
100 days of firebombing a federal
building and he didn't do anything about
it they burned down the police precincts
in Minneapolis and and these and by the
way who suffers the most
um people in the bad neighborhoods I
agree I can't get down with anyone
that's platform is that's bad that's
that's worse so put me in like for why
give me a reason to live yes you know
not just a reason to push death away
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for it out and we'll see you all
next time